this is your TV directorial debut
congratulations on that
you're so welcome why was Robin's story
a story that you felt so passionate
about telling
well you know I have to be honest
um the show runner Howard Gordon
it's from 24 and Homeland Fame
literally reached out to me
um and offered
the gig to me
um because he felt
that I would
um bring an authenticity to it
because of the subject matter
um and he was right and I really feel
really honored and humbled to be a part
of this
um new conversation
um
where these um people in positions of
Power are really putting their money
where their mouths are and giving
opportunities
for the people whose story it is to be
able to tell their own story
um you know it's a queer story
it's a complicated story and
um he trusted me with bringing the
authenticity and the Nuance
um to the telling of that story
it was it was such a great episode like
I said I've seen a few episodes but this
one really moved me I am such a fan of
the art of drag I really really am it is
such a powerful art form and what I
think is incredible is that a show like
this traditionally on network television
wouldn't always tell a black queer story
like this
um and it's it's never different story
like this it never does it they never I
I think I mean you can check you can
chat we can chat
but I don't think I've ever seen
anything like this on that on national
network television you know that's going
to
Middle America for free
well not necessarily for free but you
know basic cable prices yeah
and listen that's the incredible thing
because there is such a huge
conversation around drag right now and
drag story times for children and
there's a lot going on within the queer
Community do you think a series like
this in an episode of a series like this
can maybe hopefully change some people's
perceptions around the art form of drag
I mean that's the hope
you know the only thing that we can do
as artists
is tell the truth yeah and speak truth
to power that's what we've always been
able to do that's what we've always been
here to do
um
which I know is why
the pushback is so severe
um
you know because we speak from our
hearts and we speak from our souls and
we get in
you know we get in and we change the
molecular structure
of people from the inside out so that's
one of the reasons why I feel like
you know we're attacked so often
um from the forces
that are afraid of change
you know this legislation
you know my my my Humanity has been up
for legislation since I could comprehend
thought and the fact that that's still
happens every day and it's still
commonplace it's disgusting
what's also disgusting is this
conversation
about how if you are a drag artist which
is an art it's an art form it's
performance art it's art
it's highly elevated art
and there are forces and energies and
governments that are trying to
um connect
drag
to the molesting of children
stop that
stop it
I agree with you if no it pisses me off
too because I have so many friends who
are artists and as artists their art
form is drag This Is How They Live their
lives and they're living their lives
authentically and that's the power of
art being able to do that when we talk
about power Billy there's an interesting
thing I think when you are an authentic
person
um my career really took off when I
finally accepted who I was and the power
of who I am and I feel like for you
that's kind of the same case you've
obviously been in the entertainment
industry for a very long time but when
you finally owned exactly who Billy
Porter is do you feel like that's when
your career and the trajectory of your
career really just took off yeah that's
what everything cracked open and
continues to do so you know and I'm just
grateful that I lived long enough to see
the day
where I could sit in the fullness of my
truth and my authenticity and
my queerness
which I was told would be my liability
and was for decades transitioned into
becoming my superpower
um
it's a magical time and if there's one
thing that I can say to all the
hopelessness that exists right now is
fear not
be hopeful
because the change has already happened
right that's the point that's the thing
that nobody's talking about and that's
what I want to put at the Forefront the
change has already happened that's why
all these energies are pushing back and
Running Scared because the change has
already happened there's no putting it
back in the bottle there's no putting
the toothpaste back in the tube where
it's only going to the world only spins
forward
yeah you know the only thing constant in
our lives is change we're not going back
the answer is no I don't know what that
means right I don't know how that plays
out but the answer is no
we're not doing that we're not going
back
so here we stand at a Crossroads and as
an artist it's it's it's moments like
this with Robin's story inside of this
mainstream Middle America
construct
that we get to be a trojan horse
everything you say Billy is just so
powerful and true it really really is uh
I've loved you for such a long time
you've had a career that's really
just you've done it all which is so
incredible to me there's still things to
be done
um something there's still things to be
done but something that I love so much
is your music I loved children so great
Billy so great so it leads me to wonder
when are we getting some more music
um so I have a new single coming out
called baby was a dancer that comes out
I believe like
in a week and a half or so like March
3rd or 4th
um and then I have a full album
coming out later in the year hopefully
in June called black Mona Lisa and I'm
also I'm actually going on
a five week 30 city North American
tour
with my music for the first time in my
life I'm touring with my own music like
on a tour bus Like a Rock And Roll tour
bus you know I'm I'm a little nervous
I'm never really toured I mean the only
tour I ever did was the pre-broadway
tour of Greece
the Revival of Greece back in 1994 with
Rosie O'Donnell and Megan Mullally
before she was carried on Grease I mean
on uh uh Will and Grace so you know I am
excited and scared and terrified and
really proud of um
this new music it's my it's really truly
my magnum opus
at 53 it says all the things that I want
to say to the world it's a you know it
tells all of my truths you know in the
form that is the original gift
my voice my singing voice is the gift
from on high I find it funny and ironic
that I spent the first 20 years of my
life trying to
make people take me seriously as a an
actor and now that everybody knows I'm
an actor I read comments you know on
online where it's like oh I didn't know
pray tell good thing
you're like yeah that's the actual
thing
so I'm going back to the original Dream
and I'm excited to um
to share that with the world
well I'm excited hopefully you'll have a
tour date here in Toronto and if you do
I will be there
I will eventually absolutely
I promise you that I
now I watched a funny video of you I
watched you on uh The Tonight Show with
Jimmy Fallon where you talked about your
quests to become BFF with Jennifer Lopez
I mean who doesn't want to be BFF with
Jennifer Lopez is that somebody that you
would love to collaborate with on music
or who would be I'm trying to
collaborate with her
or like you know it could be music it
can be you know film like I actually
have a film that I would love to
collaborate with her on I started my
production company incognegro you know I
do have her number
I'm trying to not bug her you know you
got it's like I you gotta like
when you get access
you gotta like
so I'm trying to be chill about it with
her and Mr Affleck I'm just trying to be
chill maybe they'll see this
hey you can like text and be like can we
have lunch I got some some stuff I got
some stuff I need to talk about with
y'all